hello everyone and welcome back to the
stealing open we are in the semifinals
and this is the first game we're going
to show it's uh from round one magnus
cross and versus yanipanishi
and i wasn't planning on showing any
more games today i was uh planning on
showing it tomorrow but this game
ended like instantly it's incredibly
short so i thought maybe best just show
it now so without further ado
uh let's check it out magnus with the
white pieces uh
opens with d4 and this game is also
incredible
for a very specific reason that it
follows the game magnus played against
the shanatan honor in their 2014 world
championship match uh
uh well uh you you'll see what i mean by
this
so knight to f6 we have c for g6 uh
and knight to c3 and here we have d5 uh
and with this we
transpose into the groomfield defense we
have captures captures now
uh offering a trade of knights and now
bishop to d2
bishop to g7 and now e4 grabbing the
center and also forcing
forcing black to exchange knights you
could also go back but capturing is the
main line
so captures on c3 and uh nipple castles
we have queen to d2 by magnus
and now knight to c6 both players
continue developing
black putting a lot of pressure on the
d4 square so here at knight f3
adding another defender and bishop to g4
attacking one of the defenders of the d4
square
so black naturally goes d5 and here we
have a series of traits bishop captures
an f3 captures on g7 king recaptures and
captures on f3 and now comes
knight the e5 putting pressure on f3
threatening to capture it in the win
material here and here magnus castles
queen side so
up until this point it's exactly uh the
game uh between vishwanathan and magnus
carlson however
in that game anand had the white pieces
and magnus had black and here we have
c6 by black of course now you don't
capture on f3 would be pretty pointless
queen c3 check
just wins the night so you don't want to
lose the game like that
so here c6 nepo plans to bust open the
position you want to get your rook to c8
put some pressure on the white king
and now we reach the position that's
exactly the same
as uh anand's game against carlson in
the world church championship match
uh here queen to c3 was played by anand
however
magnus goes queen bishop to h3 here and
now
it is as of move 14 that we have a
completely new game
so uh now from a completely new game as
you see from the title that uh
in 16 moves we have a completely winning
position it's hard to imagine what could
go wrong here for black but
that's exactly what happens here so here
king back to g8 of course nepo is
expecting the queen to come to c3 you
don't want to have your king on a
dark g7 square and magnus goes there all
the same so queen to c3 now attacking
the knight and here we have
queen to b8 queen to c7 uh is the move
you want to play to defend the knight
because after queen to b8 it seems
reasonable because black also wants to
start attacking on the queen side
but now the position is completely
winning for magnus so feel free to pause
the video and try to find
this uh mysterious move while i give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on
completely crushing black and winning
that knight on e5 and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
d6 and after d6 it's game over uh the
knight is trapped
there's no square available for the
night all of these squares are covered
this is covered this is covered
the d7 square is covered by the bishop
so that's just it uh you have to capture
it
uh you cannot capture with the queen of
course uh because the rook
guards it so you have to capture with
the pawn and now comes f4
and now the knight really doesn't have a
square so here uh move 16
uh white is already completely winning
so nipple played a few more moves but
uh there's just now and there's just no
hope here
he played rook eight and magnus doesn't
even capture right away he says there's
plenty of time to capture let's just
continue improving our position
and nipple started pushing pawns on the
queen side a5
king b1 uh magnus even finds time for a
nice prophylactic move
a4 and only now f captures on e5 rook
captures and
f4 by magnus now challenging the rook
rook to c5
and now comes queen to f6 so uh
now preparing to bust to open the
position as the rook captures is coming
so a3 now uh black also hopes to
uh to destroy the white king's defenses
uh but now comes
b3 so not allowing this and here rook to
h5
going after the bishop but magnus says
you are more than welcome to grab the
bishop magnus plays
rook captures on the e6 and this is very
sneaky because if nipple goes for the
bishop rook e to d1 and there's no
defense against
rook 28 it's just game over
which will you know win the queen and in
the game even if you try something like
this it's still the same rook the eighth
so not not much you can do this you
you're you're losing the queen whether
you
want to or not so here nipple found
queen to e8 and now it's a little bit
different
uh but magnus finds uh finds a brilliant
move
either way so not rook to d1 right away
but first he plays
bishop to e6 and this is just this is
just insane
uh how do you how do you proceed here
there's not much you can do this you
cannot to defend
the pawn on f7 if you try something like
this then rook e to d1 is coming either
way
so you just uh win a move by doubling up
and the worst
worst of all is that if you capture
which nipple did in the game
rook e to d1 was played and it is as of
move 26 that uh
where yoni pony should resign the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so rook to d8 is coming and that's it
there's no defending against this
so this is uh one of those cases where
both players are extremely well prepared
but here
uh nepo just uh you know ran straight
into
basically what's carlson's opening
preparation and even though
nepo is known to be an extremely
well-prepared groomfeld player he he's a
he's a monster in the groomfield
he he ran into this so really crazy
stuff like i said there's no defense
against rook to d8
this is just lost even even queen f7
just rook d8 to check and after this
there's no more moves for black you're
gonna have to block it and now rook or
queen captures will be checkmate so
really awesome stuff
and uh what's uh really incredible here
is that uh
uh we have guests pretty quiet
so after this castle's queen side uh
it's really just incredible that
uh after this c6 this h3 was played and
it was possible to trap the knight like
this
uh so yeah uh i have no idea who that is
koto oh yeah it's it's the pizza guy but
uh we didn't order any pizza the people
next door uh
ordered that and then sometimes you know
they just think it's uh
our place so really really weird stuff
uh but yeah
uh that's uh the game i do hope you guys
enjoyed it we're gonna see what happens
later on and but with magnus so quick
and winning game one
uh it's gonna be it's gonna be pretty
crazy if nipple will be able to bounce
back but we'll see what happens
see meadows a great guard dog
so once again i do hope you enjoyed it
uh i would like to
thank sergey pallopas tazo sarampatsu
austin creel
juan pablo barrera and peter gauthier
and sons for your contribution to my
channel
uh thank you a lot i really appreciate
it as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
thank you i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day